bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 le 7-8 lecture chaque jour à 18h
en direct le tour de l'actualité locale
et voici les titres de ce 9 janvier à
saint cyr l'école le maire candidat
bernard debré qui dépose plainte contre
daniel garçons son opposant de gauche
ils lui reprochent les attaques sur son
éthique à daniel garçon avait dénoncé
l'utilisation de fonds publics pour
financer un sondage en cette période de
soldes de la protection des populations
intervient sur le terrain afin de
prévenir les abus et éviter les
mauvaises surprises aux consommateurs
invités de ce journal gérions son
directeur départemental fondée en 16 150
l'établissement tuyaux à choisel vient
de recevoir le prix entreprise
environnement 2013 notamment pour ses
les efforts en matière de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre l
image du jour c'est une photo la photo
de timothée installés dans les yvelines
au chesnay il a été désigné bébé cadum
du mois de décembre à 22 mois il
défendra donc les couleurs de la région
parisienne au concours national organisé
par la marque de produits d'hygiène la
finale se déroulera le 29 janvier lors
d'une cérémonie organisée au théâtre des
variétés série de plaintes donc à
saint-cyr-l'ecole en marge de la
campagne électorale voici quelques mois
le maire sortant commandait un sondage
sur les intentions de vote de sa
population sondages qu'il a été ensuite
contraint de rembourser en partie en
raison des accusations de ses opposants
de gauche seulement le candidat ump a
aujourd'hui déclaré estime que les
attaques sont allés trop loin il dépose
plainte contre le candidat soutenu par
le ps daniel garçons 4 in the late show
nous apporte plus de précisions tout est
parti de cette enquête de l'ifop
diffusée fin février dans le journal
municipal avec une partie consacrée aux
équipements de la ville et une autre sur
la popularité du maire un sondage plutôt
une enquête d'opinion pour daniel
garçons candidat divers gauche aux
municipales avec l'association anticor
elle saisie en septembre le procureur de
la république car il estime que ce
sondage payer 14350 2 euros n'aurait pas
dû être financé par la commune
je me suis étonné du fait que la mairie
allait payer un sondage qui à l'évidence
porter un certain non
deux points à caractère électoral donc
j'ai commencé à demander en mairie par
courrier les ordres de service les
ordres de paiement et en parallèle j'ai
demandé au préfet ce qu'il en pensait
voyant que je n'arrivais pas à obtenir
que bernard daubin candidats prennent en
charge une partie du sondage
il a fallu appuyer un peu plus fort et
appuyer un peu plus fort ça a été de
demander au procureur
ce qu'il en pensait une procédure que
n'a guère apprécié le maire il y a
quelques jours berlin devint porte à son
tour plainte pour diffamation contre
l'association anticor et daniel garçons
et j'estime que ya une atteinte à mon
honneur et c'est quelque chose sur
lequel je ne peut pas transiger puisque
on m'accuse de détournement de fonds à
des fins électorales c'est un sondage
qui a été entièrement public qui est et
fait plus d'un an avant l'échéance du
1er mars
donc il n'avait donc pas rentrer dans
les comptes de campagne et que la partie
du sondage que j'ai réglé moi même
lorsque j'ai reçu la facture j'ai payé
plus près de 2400 euros
si bernard de bain à payer c'est très
bien c'est exactement ce que je voulais
c'est exactement ce pour quoi j'avais
fait les actions
pour moi l'affairé entendue si elle est
entendue pour daniel garçon elle l'est
moins pour gaytten desjardins autre
conseillère municipale et candidate sur
la ville elle demande de son côté à
bernard de bain de rembourser
l'intégralité de ce sondage là non la
meilleure des preuves c'est que c'est
utilisé par tout le monde
une ambiance tendue sur la commune à un
peu plus de deux mois du premier tour
des élections municipales
on quitte la politique l'invité de ce 9
janvier gilles ruraux bonsoir vous êtes
le directeur de la protection des
populations dans le département vous
êtes forcément très attentifs en cette
période de soldes les seuls qui viennent
de débuter hier est ce que vous avez
déjà constaté des abus des excès de la
part des commerçants et puis si oui quel
type d'excès quel type d'abus alors
évidemment il est trop tôt encore pour
donner déjà un bilan
ce que l'on peut dire quand même de
manière plus générale c'est que les
soldes semblent commencer assez
doucement dans cette période où m'attend
sans doute voulu qu'un prochain
cette fréquentation il est pour
l'instant peu de fréquentation d'après
les premiers constats que l'on a
effectué alors sur les sur les
éventuelles erreurs éventuelles fraudes
ce bon alors elles sont principalement
dus lorsqu'elles sont constatées bien
sûr sur la réalité des rabais et remises
puisque c'est ce que recherche le
consommateur à savoir faire une bonne
affaire dans cette période
donc nous sommes très attentifs à la
réalité des rabais gonfle un peu les
prix artificiellement pour une règle
c'est simple qui est que le commerçant
doit pratiquer elle veut pas descendre
en dessous du prix le plus bas pratiqué
un mois avant les soldes donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle le prix de référence
donc c'est à partir de ce prix de
référence que ce calcul les rabais donc
qu'ils sont de manière libre d'ailleurs
décidé par le commerçant avant de
poursuivre cet entretien on va partir
justement pour les magasins yvelinois
premiers jours de soldes c'est et hier
nous étions présents le reportage à
maurepas
de clerck en biais dans le diwan dans ce
supermarché les salariés ont passé une
partie de la nuit à étiqueter et à
placer les produits à quelques minutes
de l'ouverture on finalise les
rayonnages tout doit être prêt pour
l'arrivée des clients
8h30 le rideau se lève derrière une
centaine de personnes bien décidées à
profiter des soldes
premier arrivé premier servi le meilleur
à car ces premiers jours séparent mais
les premières heures le magasin propose
des réductions allant jusqu'à -70%
de quoi faire des affaires et là à
chacun sa technique il y a ceux qui
fouillent et ceux qui ont bien préparé
leur âge
j'ai fait mon opéra j'espère que j'ai
fait mon bonheur
dans tous les cas les caddies se
remplissent vite même si cette année
l'enseigne prévoit une baisse de la
fréquentation
c'est vrai que le
l'élasticité moins importante quand même
que ce qu'on pouvait connaître il ya
quelques années parce que ben oui a
beaucoup beaucoup de promotions et de
l'opération tout au long de l'année
danse avec sadie lune quand même un
petit peu un petit peu l'impact des
soldes
malgré tout il reste quand même un delta
qui est non négligeable les magasins de
vêtements plus particulièrement ont
lancé des ventes privées des soldes
avant les soldes c'est tout de même dans
le textile que ce supermarché compte
faire son plus gros chiffre d'affaires
en règle générale les ventes du rayon
vêtements atteignent 100 mille euros le
premier jour et en cinq semaines de
soldes de 10 à 12% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel malgré la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat
62% des français devraient dépenser plus
de 100 euros pour les soldes une donnée
confirmée par les clients de ce magasin
si j'arrive à tout trouvé aux alentours
de 500 600 euros il reste jusqu'au 11
février pour profiter des soldes dans ce
magasin si les collections passées ne
sont pas écoulés d'ici là une partie du
stock sera donné à des associations
les clients qui attendent patiemment le
début des soldes et qui ne se doutent
pas toujours non seulement du travail
des commerçants mais aussi et du travail
de la protection de la population gilles
rue où vous intervenez commente sur le
terrain concrètement vous intervenez
masqué vous intervenez à visage
découvert lorsque vous faites vos
différents contrôles comme l'espace
intérieur n'intervient on intervient à
visage découvert bien sûr alors le
contrôle consiste principalement comme
j'ai tout à l'heure à bien regarder si
le prix de référence et scélérat b qui
sont proposés aux consommateurs sont
bien réels
ça suppose en amont un travail de
repérage aussi
d'ailleurs on l'a dit dans notre
reportage d éventuelles promotions
antérieures qui sont bien sûr tout à
fait possible un sens que vous
travaillez déjà plusieurs mondes pour la
g ralement un mois auparavant pour voir
si le prix qui sera pratiqué pendant la
période de soldes sera bien celui le
plus bas pratiqué et donc n aurait pas
été gonflé artificiellement avant les
seuls donc c'est un travail qui fait en
amont un travail de repérage et bien sûr
pendant la période des soldes
il ya les contrôles qui sont effectués
pour s'assurer d'abord de la publicité
des prix sous les 1 100 sénateurs vous
prévenez les commerçants que vous aviez
n'auront pas c'est bien sûr nous
passerons pas nous sommes à visage
découvert mais entendu et donc chaque
frame n'est pas choisir jours à l'avant
ce que vous allez venir absolument pas
les commerçants si attendu attendu ce
sont des contrôles réguliers dans la
majeure partie des cas d'ailleurs dans
80% des cas il n'y a pas de problème
particulier
comment vous choisissez les enseignes
justement que vous allez contrôler vous
nous dites c'est régulier mais vous
pouvez pas intervenir sur tout le
magasin n'était vraiment pas sur tous
les magasins l'ordre de grandeur de me
contrôler concerne 200 à 300 visites
et contrôler ils sont que je vous ai dit
repéré par les publicités qui l'ont fait
auparavant et bien entendu les grands
centres commerciaux les commerces de
centre-ville sont principalement bien
entendu font l'objet des principaux
contrôle cauris qu'un commerçant qui
gonflerait c'est prier avant de faire
les soldes alors un commerçant qui en
effet gonflerait ses prix avant les
soldes
et bien pour être poursuivis devant les
tribunaux si bien sûr le poker la
république ne décide ainsi
et donc le risque une amende importante
et vous intervenez aussi si les
consommateurs se rendent compte qu'il ya
quelque chose de pas forcément très
clair dans les soldes dans un magasin
est ce qu'ils peuvent justement saisir
la protection ne peut pas le seul humant
absolument soit par téléphone soit par
courriel le consommateur qui estime
n'avoir pas obtenu le produit désiré au
prix au prix indiqué est bien peu
absolument nous de saisir et nous
signaler des anomalies
il ya toujours une question qui se pose
aussi lorsqu'on fait les soldes
lorsqu'on achète un article on peut leur
apporter
on peut pas leur apporter le magasin
doit elle reprendre pas le reprendre là
aussi vous sortez ces primates bien
c'est une règle générale d'abord celle
du contrat si oui de manière générale un
produit ne pas être repris ni échangés
il va former que l'on voit régulièrement
dans les magasins
sauf s'il ya bien sûr ce qu'on appelle à
un vice caché avis dire les victoires ça
montre le savons il aura vices cachés
ce qui est assez rare en ce qui concerne
il faut bien le dire les produits les
plus solides et à savoir des patines pas
le textile habillement aussi donc les
chaussures tout ce qui est l'équipement
donc ça relève de l'appréciation de
chacun des magasins de reprendre non
certains articles n'est pas le cas
personne n'est pas obligé de reprendre
ni d'échangé c'est un geste commercial
qui peut bien entendu faire tout à tout
moment alors il est difficile vous me
l'avez dit forcément de faire un premier
bilan après deux jours à peine 2 de
soldes mais on peut peut-être regarder
les chiffres de l'année dernière
peut-être au niveau national il ya eu 23
1843 sont de contrôle menées par les
différents agents de vos services dans
plus de 8000 établissements dans les
yvelines qu'il est un petit peu la
proportion combien de contrôles vous
avez dans les yvelines
il ya environ 250 300 contrôles dans les
yvelines donc visites d'établissements
qui ont donné lieu à des suites
important disons de manière générale qui
a à peu près 20% des anomalies au niveau
national je continue sur ces chiffres
ses 479 procès verbaux c'est finalement
assez peu près de 3000 rappels de
réglementation 44 injonction dans les
yvelines où on est dans des proportions
un peu on est à peu près dans ses dents
dans ces proportions
c'est finalement assez faible il ya
finalement à ces bruits d'armé oui oui
il ya assez peu d' arnaque
et puis elles se traduisent dans les
faits les plus graves comme je le dis
période par des poursuites pénales
souvent il s'agit plus de négligence qui
donne lieu comme vous dites dans ad est
ce qu'on appelle des avertissements à un
concours qui seront degrés - et qui
permettent aux commerçants de rappeler
la réglementation alors là on parlait de
votre travail pendant la période des
soldes et ça va forcément se poursuivre
au cours des cinq prochaines semaines
dans le département au delà de cette
période comment se passe votre travail
quelle est votre mission tout au long de
l'année parce qu'on parle de vous
forcément cette période mais vous
travaillé toute l'année alors on
travaille toute l'année donc les
missions principales la direction de la
protection aux populations c'est
d'assurer la sécurité des consommateurs
se passe côté alimentaire à ses côtés
pour l'industriel la loyauté des
transactions mais entendu donc nous
sommes toutes année présents
sur différents champs d'action et les
soldes mais aussi bien entendu tout ce
qui est la sécurité alimentaire et
contrôles dans les restaurants et contre
la grande distribution les contrôles
aussi donc au niveau de la commande
publique de la concurrence oui on en a
on a un champ d'action extrêmement
extrêmement variés les stocks de qui se
poursuivent encore pour cinq semaines
pour terminer cette séquence
micro-trottoir quel est votre budget
pour cette période où la peau de budget
des besoins et en fonction de ce qui est
soldé ou pas soldes et je prends je
prends pas mais j'ai pas un budget à
proprement parler au départ ça varie
entre 250 300 ça dépend balla gaye
puisque moyens on arrive en fin d'année
150 euros je bois de 300 euros
non pas du tout ça m'intéresse pas les
seuls c'est toujours des chiffons c'est
des trucs qui n'ont pas été vendus
c'est pas intéressant entre 10000 et
qu'un an 70 80 euros ben pareil
nous parlions ce soir du travail
principalement de la protection de la
population concernant les fraudes
combien d'agents interviennent sur le
terrain pour le département actuellement
actuellement il ya à peu près une
dizaine d'agents qui est mobilisé sur la
question des soldats qui travailleront
encore activement pendant les cinq
prochaines semaines pendant cette
période de soldes merci gilles ruel est
revenu sur ce plateau là directeur de la
protection de la population dans le
département les seuls qui se poursuivent
attention tout de même aux arts net
merci à vous la suite du journal avec ce
prix remporté par les pépinières tuyaux
c'est un établissement fondé en 16 150
dans les yvelines
spécialisée dans la production de grands
arbres et de grands conifères il vient
d'être distingué pour ses efforts en
matière de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre olivier maniscalco patrick jacques
de dixmude se sont rendus sur place une
démarche environnementale globale
c'est sur ce principe que fin décembre
les pépinières tuyaux sont récompensés
en devenant lauréat du prix entreprise
environnement 2013 décerné notamment par
le conseil général des yvelines
cette distinction vient saluer le peu
d'impact sur l'environnement et le bilan
carbone positif de cette entreprise de
choisel créances et 150
ici les arbres ne sont
jamais arrosé durant l'année la terre et
bill et au lieu d'être désherber et des
pièges à insectes écologique remplace
les pesticides
autre technique utilisée la mycorhize
ation des champignons sont enfouis sous
terre est mise en symbiose avec les
racines
ils vont alors grossir et permettre à
l'arbre d'avoir cinq à dix fois plus
d'espacé sous terre pour se développer
ce prix a permis de nous à perdre comme
de vérifier que nos démarches
vous êtes reconnu et y compris donc ça
c'est toujours une satisfaction
et après on essaie bien sûr de prêcher
la bonne parole et de est de faire
comprendre que notre travail de qualité
doit être gérée se transmettre par
niveau du prix en termes du coup se
produire en respectant l'environnement
ça demande quand même beaucoup plus de
main d'oeuvre le fait de montrer qu'on
est très respectueux de l'environnement
permet d'essayer de justifier notamment
la pratique est supérieur à d'autres
entreprises qui sont moins respectueuses
quitus plus de désherbant par exemple
comme le circuit court dans
l'agroalimentaire la qualité
environnementale a donc un coup dans
cette pépinière c'est surtout la main
d'oeuvre deux fois plus cher que chez
certains pays concurrents comme
l'allemagne ou l'italie qui augmente les
tarifs à la caisse pour indication si
vous souhaitez acquérir un pommier ou un
tulipier âgés de 12 à 15 ans il vous
faudra débourser entre 400 et 500 euros
jusqu'à l'année prochaine les
décorations de noël vont retourner dans
les cartons aussi bien pour les
particuliers que pour les communes les
services techniques qui sont en train de
défaire avec minutie les guirlandes et
autres éléments lumineux le reportage à
magny les hameaux de la rédaction à la
nuit tombée elles ont éclairé votre
chemin pour laisser l'esprit de noël
flotter dans vos rues
clignote scintille doré verte ou bleue
leurs couleurs féeriques réchauffe les
coeurs et vous souhaite une bonne année
chaque quartier a sa décoration chaque
rue son étoile de noël mais c'est
souvent le centre-ville le plus
étincelant comme à magny les hameaux où
les anciennes lampes à incandescence ont
peu à peu laissé la place aux led plus
légère plus robuste et surtout plus
économes les années précédentes seront
tournés au fil lumière donc qui tournait
à 14 watteau mètres et la donc cette
année on tourne à 4 watteau m donc il ya
quand même une consommation moins
importante à magny les hameaux plus de
170 illuminations scintiller mais un
mois après leur installation les
guirlandes doivent repartir à l'atelier
pour laisser place aux douceur de
l'hiver et il faudra désormais attendre
un an pour que la magie de noël sont
part à nouveau de vaulruz autre univers
un moins poétique la fibromyalgie c'est
une maladie mal connue qui se
caractérise par des douleurs
articulaires de la fatigue des troubles
du sommeil également elle est tout de
même assez controversée en france bien
que reconnus par l' oms l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et elle n 13 a rencontré une personne
attend ce justement par ce trouble
marcher dans la rue monter et descendre
les escaliers des gestes du quotidien
pas si évident pour uri il ya tout juste
un an séduit en courtoise a été
diagnostiquée fibromyalgiques une
maladie caractérisée par des douleurs
musculaires dans tout le corps elle a
été déclenchée suite à un accident de la
route
j'ai traversé le passage piéton est une
dame m'a percuté sur la jambe droite
j'ai une et contribuer chez
j'ai eu un hématome je suis ressorti
boitillante on va dire de l'accident
quelques minutes après impossible de
marcher et c'est le trou noir
uri n'a plus aucun souvenir des trois
jours qui suivent l'accident
puis tout s'accélère d'abord un gros
bleu une bosse de 10 cm
la jambe droite paralysé puis des
douleurs dans tout le corps elle
enchaîne les arrêts de travail et se dit
totalement handicapés il mêle sans
certaines personnes n'aiment pas qu'on
dise
le mot handicapés on commence par une
invalidité c'est vrai mais si on vous
aide pas on devient handicapé parce que
je ne pouvais vraiment plus rien faire
mais vraiment plus rien faire jusqu'à
être ma mère elle vienne me laver parce
que j'étais dont je ne pouvais plus
bouger un bras ne pouvait plus bouger
une jambe
je le moindre geste que je pouvais faire
c'était des douleurs ou des crises on
c'est vrai qu'après ça suscite des
crises angoisse parce qu'on a peur
d'avoir mal
donc du coup c'est tout monte crescendo
on en fait mes enfants vous pouvez plus
s'approcher de moins en moins d'enfants
pour le moment il
on pouvait pas en reste avec mais ils
sont restés chez mes parents parce que
toucher à peine que ça me faisait mal en
fait je leur les douleurs donc j'ai ça
ça crée une hypersensibilité
donc en fait tout ce qui pouvait
m'arriver c'était exagéré en fait selon
le docteur hassoun si la fibromyalgie
n'a pas de cause particulière elle est
dans 40 % des cas
accompagné d'un contexte psychologique
particulier un syndrome qui associe des
douleurs diffuses généralisée à
différentes au niveau de différentes
articulations notamment mais surtout d
insertion des tendons et d'eau ton peut
faire le diagnostic avec 18 points
douloureux
ces douleurs elles ne sont pas associées
de lésions organiques ou physique on a
pu déterminer
vous diagnostiquez donc on n'a pas
d'explication physique de l'est de
l'asie au les yeux dans l'instruction
des jeunes qui explique ce type de
douleur le signe qui est associé le plus
souvent à ses douleurs c'est la fatigue
après plusieurs traitements c'est
finalement l'hypnothérapie suivi d'une
cure thermale qui soulage le plus sourit
aujourd'hui elle réhabitue tout
doucement son corps à l'effort dans un
centre de rééducation et fait quelques
exercices chez elle
je note sur un petit carnet où est ce
que je positionne à l'est
des pastilles généralement je n'ai pas
toujours au niveau du cou parce que j'ai
encore du mal et au niveau du bras sa
maladie se stabilise mais les douleurs
ne disparaîtront pas totalement des
douleurs pourtant bien réelles insiste
le médecin
et qui ne peuvent être que diminuer il
ya une réalité de la douleur faut bien
comprendre la différence entre une
douleur psychogène ligne de la psy ou de
dollars dans la tête comme ça qu'ils qui
serait une invention de dépasser ans
quand nous parle de noix psychogène
simplement comme l'étymologie le
montrent ces générés par le psychisme
les douleurs sont bien réels komori ils
seraient plus de 2 millions de français
atteints de fibromyalgie une pathologie
reconnue par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé depuis 1992
ce journal est presque terminée nous
revoyons ensemble à présent l'image du
jour cette photo 2 timothée installés
dans les yvelines au chesnay il a été
désigné bébé cadum du mois de décembre
et à 22 mois
il va donc défendre les couleurs de la
région parisienne au concours national
organisé par la marque de produits
d'hygiène
la finale qui se déroulera le 29 janvier
lors d'une cérémonie organisée au
théâtre des variétés bonne chance donc à
à timothée 7 yvelinois je vous retrouve
demain votre soirée sur tv fils c'est
notamment avec claire combier pour filer
co le magazine de l'économie de la
rédaction il sera forcément question des
soldes mais aussi de la hausse de la tva
on se quitte avec vos résolutions pour
la nouvelle année et 2014 qui débute
excellente soirée déjà faire pas mal de
travaux dans la maison qui s'accumulent
depuis des années faire un peu de sport
et un régime très sincèrement j'ai pas
très audition avait continué comme elle
est et puis
personnellement c'est qu'il fasse de moi
une femme honnête et consommables de
maigrir maigrir et puis nouvelle lui est
bien rendre service et le plus possible
aux gens qui m'entourent les aimez mais
non de prier pour eux voilà la santé je
n'ai pas vraiment une résolution non
tout va bien oui non mais bon des
résolutions de l'enjeu n'est pas
peut-être arrêté depuis mais ça si tous
les ans